افاد مراسل الجزيره بان المقاتلات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه شنت 12 عش غاره بين بلده
راميه ومنطقه جبل بلاط في القطاع الاوسط
من جنوب لبنان كما نفذت المقاتلات
الاسرائيليه غارتين على بلده العديسه في
القطاع الشرقي وتعرض محيط بلدات ميس الجبل
وامح بيب وبليد والخيام
والعديسات والمسيرات الاسرائيليه قد شنت
سلسله غارات خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه على
بلدتي عيترون وكوكبه ومحيط بلدات الطيبه
ورب 30
والعديسات على مواقع وتجمعات اسرائيليه
قباله الحدود
اللبنانيه معنا من مرجعيون جنوبي لبنان
مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي ومن الجليل
الاعلى مراسله الجزيره جيفاره البديري
ابدا معك ايهاب عن الوضع عن جديده واخر
التطورات طبعا الجانب الاسرائيلي يعتمد
بشكل شبه كامل على الاغاره بالطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي يستخدم فيها
قنابل كبيره الحجم لالحاق خسائر في
المناطق التي تغير عليها هذه الطائرات
اخرها كان في المنطقه في القطاع الغربي
حين اغارت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
12 مره على المنطقه المعروفه محليا باسم
جبل بلاط وهي قريبه من
الحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه الطائرات
الحربيه اغارت على تلك المنطقه المفتوحه
لم يسجل اي اصابات من الجانب اللبناني في
هذه الغارات التي ادت الى تصاعد اعمده
الدخان وكانت كان يمكن مشاهدتها من مناطق
مختلفه من جنوب لبنان ايضا الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه شنت غارتين قرب
المنطقه التي نقف فيها وتحديدا عند الطرف
الشمالي لبلده العديسي بين المنازل
المدنيه وقامت بالقاء صاروخين في هذه
المنطقه التي تعرضت يوم امس ايضا ل
الغارات من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه كما تعرضت لقصف مدفعي طوال
الايام السابقه المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ايضا
استخدمت بقصف منطقه لخيام منطقه لخيام تقع
على بعد اقل من كيلومتر من النقطه التي
نقف فيها
و جر اطلاق عدد من القذائف باتجاه منطقه
سهل الخيام وتحديدا المنطقه القريبه من
المنازل السكنيه دون الافاده عن وقوع
اصابات بين المدنيين او بين اي من عناصر
حزب الله وفقا لفرق الاسعاف المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه ايضا قصفت منطقه ميس الجبل
محيب بليده وكل هذه المنطقه كانت تتعرض
باستمرار لهذا القصف المدفعي نظرا
لاهميتها الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه للجانب
الاسرائيلي اذ ان منها تنطلق هجمات من حزب
الله باتجاه مواقع مختلفه للجانب
الاسرائيلي ويجري من هناك تسديد الصواريخ
والقذائف نحو المواقع الاسرائيليه وتجمعات
الجنود وهو ما يتضح من خلال الايام
الماضيه وفقا للبيانات التي اعلنها حزب
الله عن هجماته في تلك المنطقه حزب الله
لم يشن حتى هذه اللحظه اي عمليه لكن
الساعات ال 24 الماضيه اعلن فيها حزب الله
انه شن خمس هجمات باتجاه مواقع اسرائيليه
مختلفه بينها المناطق التي تعرضت لقصف
مدفعي في القطاع الاوسط وعني بها ميس
الجبل وبليد وحبيب هذه المناطق كانت ايضا
منطقه عمليات شن منها حزب الله اليوم
الماضي باتجاه المواقع الاسرائيليه حتى
هذه اللحظه الطائرات الحربيه لم تفارق
اجواء منطقه الجنوب اللبناني وكذلك
المسيرات التي تستخدمها القوات
الاسرائيليه للمراقبه والاغارة